the
constellations images in the night sky
our ancestors Drew Among the Stars they
were used for navigation fortunetelling
and storytelling different cultures had
their own constellations but our modern
ones for the most part come from the
ancient Greeks they believed the
constellations were reminders of their
great myths placed there by the gods tmy
a Greco Roman astronomer named 48
constellations in his seminal work the
alma guest in modern times the
international astronomical Union
recognizes a total of 88 constellations
in this video I want to tell the stories
these constellations Express we're not
going to go over everyone we'll focus on
Tommy 48 and we won't cover all of those
either you see not every constellation
has its own unique story and many groups
of constellations work together to tell
larger stories and knowing these stories
can help you remember the constellations
better and relate to the stars in a more
meaningful
[Music]
way this video is brought to you by my
patreon if you'd like to support me in
what I do or if you'd like the perks
that come from being a patron go to
patreon.com papers or click the link in
the description to join thanks very much
and now back to the video
we'll start off with the myth of
Perseus Perseus was a demigod a son of
Zeus and one of the most celebrated
Greek Heroes his constellation is best
seen on nights in December for the
Northern Hemisphere at least sorry to my
friends in the southern hemisphere but
I'll be discussing viewing these
constellations from a northern
perspective Perseus was most famous for
slaying the snake-haired
Medusa Perseus while expert L avoiding
her petrifying gaze decapitated her and
from her blood sprang Pegasus Pegasus
was a winged horse and Son of the seag
god Poseidon and Medusa well
Perseus uh released him by cutting off
his mother's head he did not in fact
tame the horse as is seen in some Modern
adaptations of the myth Pegasus was
instead tamed by a later hero named
bapon the constellation pag pus is best
seen in
October between Pegasus and Perseus in
the sky is the constellation Andromeda
on his way back from killing Medusa
Perseus came across a terrifying sight
the Ethiopian princess Andromeda tied to
a rock waiting to be eaten by the sea
monster cus Perseus then killed the
monster and rescued the princess who he
eventually
married Andromeda and cedus are best
seen in November though luckily for
Andromeda they are not in the same patch
of Sky the next two constellations are
copia and cus they were the queen and
king of Ethiopia respectively and also
mother and father to princess Andromeda
you see copia had bragged that her
daughter was even more beautiful than
the nads this enraged the cyms as well
as posidon who sent cedus to destroy
Ethiopia unless Andromeda was sacrificed
to the monster
sephus reluctant but pressured by his
subjects who very much did not want to
be destroyed by a giant sea monster
agreed to sacrifice his daughter and it
was then that pereus saved Andromeda and
defeated cetus winning andromeda's hand
in marriage copia is one of the easiest
constellations to see and identify like
Andromeda and cus she is best seen in
November look for her five brightest
stars that create a w or M m
shape cus is just west of his wife
assuming she is in her M
formation so those are these six
constellations as part of the pereus
myth pereus himself Andromeda copia cus
cus and
Pegasus next we have the story with the
most constellations in it the myth of
Hercules Hercules was the greatest most
celebrated of all the Greek Heroes he
like Perseus was a son of Zeus he's most
famous for his 12 Labors the TW labors
of Hercules tasks given to him by the
king
Urus some of these labers are
represented in the constellations first
we have Hercules himself as I said he
was a son of Zeus and Immortal woman
named
Alini Hera the queen of the gods was
rightfully angry at Zeus's constant
infidelity and took out her frustration
not on Zeus but on his son therefore
Hercules's life was constantly
threatened and made Difficult by an
angry Hera the Hercules constellation is
best seen in the summer in July Now we
move to the 12 labors for context
Hercules had married a woman named Meara
and had two children with her Hera who
just couldn't let go of a grudge made
Hercules lose his mind and in a state of
temporary insanity Hercules killed his
wife and children terrified and
distraught at what he had done Hercules
prayed to Apollo the God of Prophecy and
the Oracle of Deli told Hercules to work
for King Urus for 12 years as punishment
for his crimes so we come to the first
labor to slay the nimian lion it is
represented Ed by the constellation Leo
our first of the 12 zodiac
constellations around the town of nemia
there was a lion terrorizing the
countryside many tried to slay it but
its coat was as hard as bronze and no
sword or Arrow could pierce it Hercules
similarly saw that his arrows did
nothing to the Beast so he chased it
into a cave and there strangled the lion
to death with his bare hands her KES is
often depicted wearing a lion's skin
though it's unclear if this was from The
nean Lion Leo is recognizable by this
sickle shape in the sky and it's best
seen in April Hercules's second task was
to slay the lerian Hydra the Hydra was a
bog monster with nine heads in fatal
Venom Hercules tried to bash the
monsters heads with his Club but each
time one head was smashed two more grew
back in its place to make matters worse
Hera sent a giant crab to nip at
Hercules's ankles and slow him down so
he would be killed by the Hydra the plan
failed as Hercules smashed the crab
quite easily Hercules eventually found
that he could burn and cauterize the
wounds of the Hydra making it so that no
new heads would grow he called upon his
nephew aolis Who Was His companion on
this journey to burn the severed next
after he killed each one Hydra and
cancer the Giant Crab were placed in the
sky together by Hera both are best seen
in the spring around March and April as
I said before not all the labors are
remembered in the constellation so we
have to skip a few to get to our next
constellation Hercules's seventh labor
was to capture the creton bow you see
the king of creit Minos had promised
Poseidon he would sacrifice whatever
animal Poseidon sent him the sea God
sent a huge bull to creit but Minos
thought it so beautiful that he
sacrificed a different animal instead
Poseidon was furious at King minus'
broken oath and made the Bull Run
Rampage through the island as further
punishment the sea god made minos's wife
paf fall in love with the bull and from
their Union the minitar was born who
would later be killed killed by the
Athenian hero Theus anyway Hercules was
easily able to capture the bull and
bring it back to King Urus Theus the
bull is represented by the constellation
Taurus another of the 12 zodiacs and can
be best seen in
January the 11th labor was to fetch the
apples of the Hesperides the apples nor
the tree they grew from are depicted in
the stars but two events that happened
on Hercules's Quest for the apples are
first Aquila the eagle and sageta the
arrow so some more background there was
once a Titan named Prometheus who was
punished by Zeus for stealing fire from
the gods and giving it to mankind his
punishment was to be tied to a rock and
have his liver eaten every day by a
giant eagle on the Journey to Find The
Garden of the Hesperides where the
golden apples GRE grew Hercules came
across Prometheus tied to his Rock
Hercules feeling bad for Prometheus shot
the eagle down with an arrow and freed
Prometheus the Titan was so grateful
that he told Hercules how to get to the
apples the eagle Aquila and the arrow of
Hercules called sageta were put in the
Sky by Zeus both can be seen best in the
month of
August the quest was not over however
the apples were guarded by the esperides
nymphs who were the daughters of the
Titan Atlas the one who holds up the sky
and by aund headed dragon named leadon
in one version of The Myth Hercules
tricked Atlas into getting the apples
for him this version doesn't really
mention the dragon as a factor though so
we'll go with the alternate version that
sees Hercules killing the dragon and
taking the apples himself lat on the
dragon is represented by the
constellation Draco it can be best seen
in
July so those are the constellations in
the Hercules myth Hercules Taurus Leo
cancer Hydra Draco Aquila and
sagitta we have two more minor myths to
go over now the first is the myth of
Jason and the Argonauts and the second
Orion the
hunter Jason himself is not counted
amongst the stars but two of his
companions as well as as other parts of
his myth are we'll start with the Argo
itself the famous ship that Jason and
his Argonauts sailed to find the Golden
Fleece the Golden Fleece was the skin of
a golden Ram named chry amus it was said
to have magic powers of protection and
Jason was sent to fetch the fleece by
his uncle King pelus to prove Jason was
the rightful King of thessaly the Argo
is the largest classical constellation
so large in fact that it was broken into
three distinct constellations Karina the
Keel puus the stern and Vela the sails
all three can be best seen in March
chamalis the golden Ram is represented
by Aries one of the zodiac signs it can
be best seen in December Jason rounded
up a crew of Heroes to help him on his
quest including Hercules another two
Argonauts were casor and Pollock known
collectively as the
dioscuri the dioscuri were actually very
popular heroes in ancient Greece often
worshiped as Gods Caster was the Mortal
son of tarius the King of Sparta and
Lita his wife Pollock whoever was the
son of Zeus and Lita you see Zeus ever
the promiscuous God wanted to sleep with
Lita and so he transformed himself into
a swan and seduced her but she was
already pregnant with her husband's
child
therefore while casor and Pollock were
twins they were actually only half
Brothers yeah Greek mythology is wild
signis the swan constellation represents
Zeus in his Swan form and Gemini
represents the dasuri signis can be seen
in September and Gemini in February one
last constellation in the Jason Mythos
Jason before his quest was tutored by
the centaur kir on who is the wisest and
best of the centaurs he's represented by
Sagittarius one of the zodiac and he can
be best seen in August so those are the
constellations that relate to the myths
of the Argonauts the Argo Aries Gemini
signis and
Sagittarius Orion is one of the most
noticeable constellations in the sky but
most don't know his story he was one of
the Giants a race of people in Greek
mythology that had great strength though
weren't necessarily of great size he was
a renowned Hunter so renowned that
Artemis goddess of the hunt who did not
usually associate with men enjoyed
hunting with him Orion however made a
mistake the classic mistake that all
Greek Heroes make boasting of his
prowess he stated that he was such a
great hunter that he would hunt and kill
every beast in the world Gaia mother of
all creation took issue with this
statement and so sent a giant scorpion
to kill him it succeeded and Artemis
placed Orion in the sky as a
constellation along with kis major his
hunting dog and two animals for him to
hunt forever canis Miner The Fox and
lepus the
hair the Scorpion was also placed in the
heavens as Scorpius another of the
zodiac Orion and lepus can be best seen
in January look out for these three
stars called Orion's Belt kis major and
minor can be seen best in February and
Scorpius in
July the constellations don't just
represent images or tell stories they
can connect us with people long past
when you have a moment find a place with
little light pollution and do yourself
the favor of looking up and realize
these same stars have been inspiring us
guiding us and amazing us for thousands
of
years well that's it for this video if
you like it enough I might do a sequel
there are lots of other constellations
to go over I mean I didn't even talk
about all 12 zodiacs do me a favor and
hit that like button and subscribe if
you haven't also if you want to help out
the Channel please consider donating to
my patreon the links in the description
bye